thursday which can only mean one thing
it's time to recap last night's episode
of survivor 42.
yeah i think it's safe to say that the
reality series definitely isn't all fun
and games especially when you're getting
down poured with rain uh in fiji it's
cold no
come on in
day 18. oh man we're loving survivor 42.
all right how are we doing
day 18 i know it's not easy but are you
feeling that you're nearing the end
that you can do this
playing a game jeff we're playing the
game
it's been a rough night
but we're playing survivor so it's all
good
and now we're joined by our very own
survivor correspondent and season 41
winner erica kasoopenin hello erica hi
kate hi keisha as always it's good to be
back to chat all things survivor
okay girl i need to know how cold is
that rain out there in fiji i mean it
obviously sucks but what's worse is when
it's night it's raining and then the
rain stops because your clothes are
soaked through and then it's just the
ocean breeze hitting you oh
oh my goodness that does not sound so
comfortable all right uh now although we
witnessed a real brutal blind slide last
night we first have to talk about our
canadian omar who looks like he's really
running the game and has potential to
make it to the final three so erica i
want to know what are your thoughts on
his gameplay well i think omar obviously
had an amazing episode he manipulated
mike by telling him that hai said that
mike was his puppet and i think what's
great about omar's manipulation is he
really understands everybody's
motivations and uses that to really
figure out what to tell them to get them
to do what he wants i think the issue i
don't want to see a problem but the
issue omar has right now is he has all
of these alliances with all of these
people one-on-one and if any of those
people start to compare notes then omar
could be in a bit of trouble so i'm
rooting for omar we'll see if he can
make it to the end
so let's fast forward to the immunity
challenge where we saw another dominant
performance from jonathan erica are his
strengths and the challenges not an
immediate
red flag to the other castaways like why
is he still in the game
i mean
a challenge beast does not a survivor
winner make and i think that one can be
great at challenges but we've seen in
previous episodes jonathan is not strong
strategically sorry um he had a rough
performance in the last tribal council
so i think that even though somebody is
winning at challenges even if he makes
it to the end it's going to be hard for
the jury to really reward that game play
unless he really steps it up
strategically
yeah sorry boo you see uh and despite
feeling confident uh he had the numbers
to sway the vote uh hai was especially
blindsided which he took very well might
i add um erica was high the right choice
to send home over jonathan i think
unfortunately for hai it was the right
choice as i said jonathan not the
strongest strategically but then high on
the other hand hai has proven that he's
able to influence the game he plays
aggressively he's able to really move
things around to get what he wants and i
think ultimately that's going to be a
bigger threat than aquaman will ever be
and earlier today i actually spoke with
hai about the shocking tribal council
well i feel like your exit really stood
out because it looked like you took that
blind side really well so what were you
thinking when jeff read the votes
you know
when people have like near death
experiences and they talk about like
seeing the white light and like their
life flashing before their eyes it was
very accurate as you're getting
blindsided right as my name kept coming
up every conversation that i had that
afternoon was like
rushing back to me but in like a
different context and people's answers
at tribal all of a sudden the subtext
changed right like when
lindsay said tonight's theme is about
evening the playing field i thought she
was humble getting rid of jonathan so
that we could all like have a shot at
like immunity but she was talking about
getting rid of me
like as the strategic threat so that
they would have a better opportunity and
i was just astonished at the level of
gameplay this season so when i got
blindsided i felt a lot of pride not
just for myself but for like my
castmates who were who are here to play
i mean i've never been voted out so i've
never experienced the white lights but i
will just take his word for it that
sounds